hey guys I just wanted to say hi see how
you're all doing a lot of you been
asking me to make a video talking about
all the craziness that's been going on
and I don't normally do these types of
videos and one of the reasons that I
haven't made this video or really talked
about it much on social is I don't want
to be the source of misinformation
because I have seen so many people
posting so many different things
retweeting things and that later turns
out to be just false information so
that's one of the things that I've been
very very careful about because I know
in the past you see something you
immediately react you retweet it and
then that just spreads like wildfire
which is sort of what is happening with
this whole virus and what makes it so
scary and I think one of the scariest
parts about this is the unknown we don't
know which is why people are panic
buying everyone is freaking out and I
just don't really know what to do or
what to say so I've just kind of been
trying to keep myself entertained you
know with memes because trying to make
light of the situation even though it is
not at all a situation to be taken
lightly is sort of how I cope and what
I've been doing to sort of deal with it
it's just really strange because I don't
think we've ever expected anything like
this I've been sort of just prepping for
like an earthquake with like some extra
batteries or I don't know like a little
to go bag that has some yoga pants and a
packet of coffee in it like that's not
being prepared for anything at all like
this not too long ago I was like a
couple weeks ago a few of my friends
were like hey you should probably stock
up on some things and just you know
what's that's what you have and I I did
I have like I did if something had
happened a few weeks ago I wouldn't even
be able to survive for a day off of the
food that I had in my house I mean even
now I don't have enough to survive for
very long at all so I've kind of been
assessing the things that I do have like
the bread that I have I've put in the
freezer to make that last longer and
it's just such a strange strange thing
because a lot of us especially my
generation we live in the now the
immediacy
of post mates of prime now which I could
order anything that you wanted no matter
what it is you I ran out of English
muffinz I would be able to get English
muffinz within 20 minutes and now prime
now is not even accepting orders the
last time that I was able to place an
order it took two days when it normally
would take 15 minutes so this isn't just
something that is impacting us
health-wise like it's impacting
everything around us the supply the
demand for these every day set items so
I think that if you are one of those
people that are going crazy and hoarding
things reach out to your friends to your
family ask them if they have any
extended friends or family that are in
need of this stuff and help them out
because right now coming together as a
community is honestly really all that we
can do and panic buying and fighting
people in grocery stores is not
something that you should be doing and
if you are there and you are confronted
by somebody who is yelling meat that
yelling with kindness and understanding
and knowing that they are also having
the same crazy thoughts that you're
having and if you can sort of meet them
and bring them down to your very calm
subtle level you might be able to reason
with them and I mean I don't I don't
know that's just how I usually react to
those situations I've been confronted by
people before not this is not
entertaining to this but just people who
are add an escalated heightened I don't
know mad about something like traffic
like there's a just a traffic stop once
and like this one was like yelling at me
and I was just like okay stay calm
because she clearly is very upset or
angry about something I'm like I'm I
don't know that's a whole other side
story but I tried to meet her at a lower
lower level and it ended up
de-escalating the situation so for me
that's how I usually handle things and I
think that if we can just be as kind as
we can to people right now it's the most
important thing ever because so many
people are impacted by this it's not
just me
you it's everyone this is everybody in
the entire world is affected about this
restaurant owners I can't even I just
seeing what's happening in grocery
stores is so just beyond shocking so if
you are there and you're at the grocery
store just be as kind as you can to the
employees if you are one of those
employees I applaud you everyone who is
working through this in the healthcare
industry because people do get panicked
and they do get upset because so much is
happening no one knows what's happening
and you know I think that as we're going
through what we're doing and what we're
going through right now is it's as
terrorists not a good thing but I think
the outcome of it can be very positive I
think a lot of us reassessing things
that are important the things that we
should have in our houses as necessities
if something like this were to ever
happen again what do you really need
like what actually matters a lot of
things really don't and I think just
having that be reassessed I think it's
very very important not only for oh you
know us as a community but us as a world
like really when you think about it like
what does matter and I think it just
puts a lot of things into perspective I
think a lot of us have needed to kind of
reassess things obviously this is not
the way that we would want it to be
reassessed having to go through anything
like this but I guess really all we
could do now number one suggestion is is
be kind I think that's really gonna be
important wash those hands keep things
as clean as possible
the whole social distancing thing I had
you know everyone's making light of it
but it it really is effective because if
you are infected there's not enough
tests right now to be able to test if
you actually do have it so nobody knows
when a Tom Hanks when I saw their
talking is a corona I mean that is no
one is safe you know it doesn't matter
how much money you have what status
level you are what
it doesn't matter like your health is
such a priority and I did a post not too
long ago on Twitter and Instagram some
of you guys might not actually follow me
there so if you don't I mean I put a
link to a little medium post that I
wrote talking about my jujitsu journey
and how when I got an injury for me that
it felt like everything was just
completely over like everything that I
had been working for and training and I
think right now I'm sort of using that
same mindset like okay I can't do a lot
of things but what can I do to better
myself
while we're in this situation so during
my jujitsu injury I was like okay so I
can't train I can't do a lot of things
so what can I do I can do yoga I can I
can still lift weights I can still do
other different things to try to get my
body back in shape while this injury
heals so that sort of mindset it's kind
of what I'm having right now the past
few days I have definitely felt just
weird like just I think it's all sort of
set in like I I just didn't really want
to do anything and I wasn't working out
and then I was like this is gonna put me
into a mood knowing myself and how
quickly I can spiral down into where I
don't want to be I was like today
there's no excuses you're gonna you're
gonna get up they're gonna workouts
watch some YouTube videos there are so
many resources and workout videos on
YouTube so there's honestly no excuse
for any of us to not be able to workout
if you have a very small space doesn't
matter you could do some yoga
you can stretch you can move your body
and I think that's something that we
really need to do right now so if you've
never worked out in your entire life
start now we've got a lot of free time
and I think just putting that energy
towards bettering yourself while we're
in this crazy crisis I think it's just I
mean that's that's really what I plan on
doing I do plan on still making videos I
do work from home all the time
I am very used to that so I think for a
lot of
people you know you're not used to that
so I think adjusting to that new type of
lifestyle make yourself a schedule I'm
not very good at sticking to schedules
so I am somebody who needs that routine
and schedule more than those people so I
don't know if you do need a schedule
just write it out you're gonna work out
in the morning I like to make sure that
I work out before I start doing anything
else because if I don't I will get
distracted and the day gets carried away
Maddie stop honey stop I'm making a
video to my friends so I don't even know
what I've said in this video I talked a
lot I'm not even gonna edit it I just
really wanted to address a few things
and just know that you know things get
low they do always go back up I don't
know if we've seen the worst of this and
if we haven't seen the worst of it we
will all figure it out you have to be
calm and I don't really know and I feel
like a lot of my life I haven't known
the future or outcome of things but I
think just knowing that things will get
better it's gonna be a matter of time be
kind wash your hands and I don't even
sure what I said this video but I just
know that we're all going through this
together you're not alone so if you do
feel alone reach out to people
thankfully this is the internet there's
an incredible community of people and if
you guys want to chat in my comments
feel free take this from this YouTube
video take it to Twitter take it to
Instagram make yourself some new friends
and that really is the joy of the
internet like if this would have
happened
you know what any other time I mean
things like this have happened in the
past but at least now we are able to
talk about it we are able to stay
connected and sometimes you know we that
could also be scary because the media
everything just it just blows out of
proportion so fact check make sure you
guys are doing your own research and
don't just rely on the media make sure
you're looking at a bunch of different
outlets because I've read things already
I'm like this doesn't seem true so
I go through I do some fact checking and
I realize no that wasn't true but I'm
gonna I'm gonna go I love you guys
I will look forward to chatting to you
guys in the comments so feel free to
leave those below I'll be hanging out
here maybe I'll do a livestream I don't
know but we can get through it together
I love you guys bye